welcome to  part two of documentary day at the  director's close-up  i'm really happy with the movement to  miniseries more economical for the  filmmakers generally and it's more  economical for the buyers they get more  bang for their buck  to be able to get a certain level of  sincerity and authenticity and still be  able to  create beautiful images is just  something that keeps getting better  then the tools are shrinking and two or  three or four people cruise  could actually make amazing cinematic  quality we were having fun  kind of chasing down this bad guy we  felt like an audience would also enjoy  it  we're basically being very responsible  trying to tell these people's stories  i'm really interested i'm really  listening i i really care  you're really tired of the drone shots  on hiding  i got i'm like hey should we fly the  drone we have so many in our new film